This episode is made possible by the realistic online game war thunder.
Check out this game through the link in the description below.
Go through that link and you're not any support this show,
which is nice of you.
They'll also get a free premium tango Aircrafts and three days of premium time
as a bonus for registering and let's get into it.
Nikita Khrushchev,
surname name is still enough to conjure images of flying missiles and nuclear
devastation.
The Soviet premier who succeeded Stalin Khrushchev was a Russian bear of a man
and Olga who banged his shoe on a podium at the United Nations and told
Americans,
we will bury you.
His rule in the 1950s and the 1960s coincide with the height of the red scare in
the u s since for a generation he was the West's ultimate boogeyman.
He was indeed the man who engineered the Cuban missile crisis that nearly ended
the world,
but there is much more to Khrushchev than Cuba and nuclear war.
The first peasant leader of the USSR,
he was a zealous reformer who tore down the buddy edifice of stolen aneurysm
under Khrushchev.
Swatch prisoners were freed,
communism was liberalized and life was improved for millions of people yeti
through all of this away with international theatrical that ultimately led to a
Soviet cool.
So was he the bad guy of the 20th century or was he just a misunderstood
reformat?
Well,
today we are diving into the life of the USSR,
the most controversial premiere,
although you would publicly identify with the Ukraine for most of his life.
Nikita Khrushchev was actually born in [inaudible] in Russia on April the 17th
1894 Chris Chefs family,
well,
the exact sort of people,
the communists idealized.
His father was a coal miner and his grandfather had been a surf who served in
the SARS army.
The only discordant note in this otherwise perfect proletarian upbringing was
the heavy presence of religion,
not the Khrushchev would have any problems ditching Christianity later in life
when he was just the land cruise ships,
parents moved across the border two years off and Ukraine,
which is now [inaudible],
it was in,
it was off cause grim industrial wasteland that Khrushchev finally found his
calling.
He got a job as a pipe fitter,
age 15 before becoming a skilled metal workup and his teenage hotter.
Dream it again,
some blue.
My dream of becoming an engineer runs a man of standing in Russian imperial
society.
Even married an educated woman who encouraged his ambition,
but this modest stream,
it was a balance to be swept away by a tsunami.
On June the 28th 1914 a Serbian terrorist assassinated Austrian archduke Franz
Ferdinand in Sarajevo belly.
A month later,
the whole of the Russian empire was marching towards to protect Serbia from
Austrian retaliation and this has,
he might know mark at the beginning of World War One,
but while Chris jazz vital factory work,
he kept him from enlisting in the army.
He wouldn't be able to avoid what came next on march the eighth 1917 frustration
at nearly three years of badly run warfare.
It's exploded across Russia,
the February revolution.
So cool,
cold because the Russian embassy still use the old Julian calendar,
topple the saw and place the empire in the hands of the provisional government
in Ukraine.
People,
they went nuts.
The saws.
Hated regime was gone and ordinary people,
they were in charge writing this heavyweight of optimism.
Khrushchev signed up with a new Bolshevik posse.
It was just in time.
On November the seventh of 1917 Vladimir Lenin engineered the October
Revolution,
the Bolsheviks storms,
the winter palace in Petrograd,
over through the provisional government and declared a socialist republic.
This was one of the biggest single events of the 20th century.
Ben's,
it had immediate consequences in Ukraine.
Civil war erupted.
It's pissing the red fortunes of Bolshevism against the white forces of the
sock.
It was couple of it further by uprisings of Ukrainian nationalists since later
an invasion by the Polish army.
Does that mean Steve presented as Dobson Republic Khrushchev in this and in the
Red Army in 1919 and he was sent to the Polish border for the next three years.
He fought the poles and the pro royalist whites until on October the 25th 1922
the Red Army finally declared victory that December the u s I saw it was
officially created back in what was now the Ukrainian Soviet socialist republic.
Khrushchev,
he demobilized,
but there was no time for celebration.
Just as the war ended.
Khrushchev's first wife,
she died.
Some sources say it was from famine,
brought about by the conflicts.
Others say that she contracted typhus left with two children to raise the now
adult Khrushchev.
He returned to his old alpha and enrolled in the Soviet work as school
determined to complete his education.
Much later it would be said that this more than the Ami is where Khrushchev
discovered his loyalty to the new regime under the saw,
a poor peasant from the Ukraine,
Russia border would have no chance of getting even a high school education.
Now the communists were in power.
Khrushchev was suddenly able to access a world of knowledge once reserved for
Russia's elite.
Perhaps that's why not long after he enrolled Khrushchev,
he took a major step one which would affect both his life and the lives of
everyone in the Ussr.
He became the leader of the zone because students communist party
Khrushchev's rise up the Soviet system.
It wasn't dramatic.
Rather than shoot to the top of the former presidents,
he rose slowly but surely.
It started with a promotion to the leader of the as African region Communist
Party.
Then there was reassignment to the biggest city of caucus then from that or it
was to a position at the top if the KF potty for man had been a pipe cleaner
just a decade before loading is over.
Metropolitan Kiev should have been enough that Khrushchev,
he wants it more than Ukraine was able to given.
In 1929 he went to Moscow provisional that to study metallurgy.
In reality,
it was to build a power base in no time at all.
Christian was put in charge of constructing the Moscow subway and incredibly
important assignments.
He carried out his so well that the party maize in the communist equivalents of
the governor of Moscow by 1936 Khrushchev,
he was an influential rising star with a strong power base in both Moscow and
the Ukraine.
It's a description that should have seen him as one of the first to die in the
great purge.
Last thing from 1936 to 1938 the great purge was Stalin's unhinged killing spree
against anyone with a power base driver zone.
If you've seen our video on an KVD head of entry barrier,
you know know that even ultra loyalists like barrier nearly died in Stalin's
witch hunts by rights Christian story.
It should sort of end here with him being shot in the back and some of them
anonymous Moscow courtyard on a chilly night that's Khrushchev had a quality
that no one else in the party hands during the great purge,
a quality that would save his life and that quality.
He was ridiculous.
Yeah,
far from being respected.
Khrushchev,
he was regarded as a total joke.
He was barely five foot two inches tall and he looks like some Ukrainian village
idiots.
He drank like a fish and started would sometimes make them do funny dances to
entertain on the party leaders.
It was this amazing combination.
While the vast majority of powerful communists were out being murdered,
Khrushchev was loudly supporting style in,
in public and acting as the Tyrons gesture in private as a results.
Khrushchev not only survived the great Paj,
but he benefited from it.
In 1938 he was made a member of the political bureau and elevated to the
position of leader of Ukraine.
Back in his old stomping ground.
Khrushchev kept cultivating his image of a stolen loyalist on the old bands
orders.
He oversaw all the bloody Soviet invasion of eastern Poland's before organizing
resistance to Hitler as 1941 invasion of the USSR.
It's cool.
The next few years bloody would do a massive disservice to blood.
From 1941 June,
1944 the Nazis occupied Ukraine killing around 7 million people.
When Khrushchev regains control,
he conducted his own purge of German aligns Ukrainians.
This was then followed in 1946 by a famine that killed another million people.
It is this last catastrophe that started Khrushchev's slow drift from Stalin
aneurysm.
The famine was exacerbated by Soviet collective farming and grain quota.
Something which appalled Khrushchev,
who you have to remember,
he loved Ukraine like it was his homelands.
Not that his disillusionment would come into the open just quite yet.
In 1949 Chris Jeff was recalled to Moscow by stone and as part of the old man's
plans,
a balanced power and is in a circle alongside of entry barrier.
Deputy Prime Minister Nicholi Bulgan in and second body secretary,
Gorgon Mountain Golf,
Khrushchev became a fixture at Starland dacha.
Wow.
Once again,
the tire is made,
the this'll Ukrainian.
Dawn's is a funny little dance first,
Jeff,
the next few years,
and they were miserable away from his power base in Ukraine.
They in the part of court gesture Stalin,
he lives a life of low grade team in the Asian,
but something was about to happen that would shake up not just the lives of
Khrushchev Barrier Bogan and Amalin cove,
the lives of the entire communist world,
and that's because now it's time to discuss the death of Stalin.
Okay.
On march the first 1953 or seven tendered Stalin's bedroom to find the dictator
lying unconscious in a pool of his own urine.
The man of steel,
he had suffered a stroke,
although he would cling on for a few more days.
It was the beginning of the end for styling aneurysm.
It was as as say,
the beginning of the beginning for Khrushchev's rise to power at the moment of
Stalin's death path to succession.
Well,
it was Maria than the actual mud in terms of position.
Georgia and melancholy,
I've had the best claim to the throne,
but the wily barrier had the power of these to propel himself to clear front
runner,
Chris Chef.
He was a seconds or maybe even a third tier choice,
even molars off who'd recently been on Stalin's kill list was seen as more
influential power,
very cat British chef.
He was also a man who was often underestimated and that allows him to move
against the others before they realized what was happening.
Within nine days of Stalin's death,
Malin cough,
it had been sidelined.
Barrier assumes this mentored one and started enacting his own liberalizing
reforms,
but in the shadows,
Khrushchev watched just biding his time.
When Barry has reformed this,
triggered a workers' revolts in east Germany.
He pounced on June the 26th 1953 Khrushchev denounced barrier in a closed
meeting.
Nylon golf by now on Khrushchev's side called in the Red Army.
Soldiers and barrier was shocked.
Debt in the Optima.
Khrushchev secured the poster,
First Secretary of the Communist Party with melancholic having the position of
premiere,
but it was clear who was really in charge.
Khrushchev's rule.
It started slowly.
These badges,
first year sidelining Malakov patching things up with starlings old enemy Tito
in Yugoslavia and transferring Crimea to the Ukraine.
Something that would later cause problems,
as you're probably aware.
Then on February the 25th of 1956 Khrushchev abruptly changed gear,
the change.
It was a speech delivered before the 20th Party Congress.
It's known today as the secret speech because it was only ever meant to be heard
by party officials,
but the reality was that someone had leaked it to the New York Times clocking in
at six hours.
The speech demolished Stalin's personality cults.
It criticized the dead leader for killing innocent communists during the great
purge and quoted a long suppressed letter written by Lenin advising that Stalin
never be given power to more than the as Khrushchev's speech.
It actually seems pretty weak.
The only aspect of Stalin's rule does or attack.
So the bits that directly affected law of Party members like Khrushchev,
not the campaigns of terror and the starvation that killed millions.
At the time,
though it was a shocking as if Khrushchev had thrown a live grenade from the
podium for two decades.
The party had been brainwashed into thinking that Stalin was the greatest world
leader rather than,
and now the big men success was telling them that starring was a tyrant.
This speech,
it triggered something called the Chris Jeff thought.
Over the next few years,
millions of political prisoners,
they were released and censorship which relaxed.
This was the start of a new era for the U S I saw,
although this brave new world would still be repressive,
it would be a utopia compared to how things were understanding.
There were some exceptions.
The news of the speech triggered a revolution in communist Hungary,
which crew should have crushed as brutally as Stalin would have.
On the other hand is when the speech also triggered an uprising and Poland's
Khrushchev flew to Warsaw and signed a deal of giving the independent communist
republics of eastern Europe previously unheard of autonomy,
whether the party likes it on us,
things they were changing from that and golf and molars of though the feeling
was very much not.
In June of 1957 they organized a coup to topple Khrushchev and return a
Stalinist system and it nearly worked.
I've worked in the political bureau actually passed to depose Khrushchev and it
was only guessing the hero of the Red Army Marshall Zuke of onsite that saved
Khrushchev but somebody if he did expanding mountain coven molars,
Alvin's even having his allies,
you called removed from power by March of 1958 there was no energy left in the
Stalinists.
Khrushchev became the undisputed leader of the USSR.
Now it was the only game in town.
Now just before we get into the USSR and decrease Jeff,
I do want to thank today's sponsor war thunder
once this like war thunder help us make these super long videos which with a
topic like this which is often demonetized,
it's you know,
it's helpful.
So if he wants all the fun of battle without you know the real death and horror
that you're hearing about in today's video,
you should absolutely check out war thunder.
It's a realistic free to play military vehicle combat game Wathen is available
on PC ps four Xbox one so if you've got any of those devices you're covered but
you only need one.
Only you need to do is just download and play the game.
It's free and they need to purchase and in this game there are over 1,200
historically accurate vehicles all the way from the 1920s to the 1990 so really
covering that time period you heard about in today's video,
they're all carefully built and incredibly detailed and all the physics has been
really sweated over.
So that's all very,
very good.
Sound as great as well.
Just go watch a trailer or maybe we'll play a bit of it now so you can get a
feel for that
and a,
you can just jump in,
play a quick arcade game,
which is useful.
You don't have much time or you could be realistic mode for a more challenging
tactical scenario or if you're hardcore,
I'm not,
I haven't blade simulator.
It's apparently very,
very difficult.
I didn't like getting my all swept over and over again,
but if you're really up for a challenge,
try that mode.
So join us on the battlefield for free.
Using the link below doing that.
Like I said,
it supports this show.
I guess you're a free premium tank or aircraft and three days of premium time as
a bonus just for registering.
And let's get back to our story of the u s as saw and how it does.
How does the new leader shall we,
the next few years,
we're a dizzying time via average Soviet citizen.
If you imagine the USSR as a battered old car that's been puttering along under
Stalin Khrushchev,
his rule was like watching a drunken madmen grabbed the wheel and go veering off
on a demanded and possibly dangerous new course for the first time.
Honest to God can seem a products.
They appeared on shelves in bookstores,
subversive literature.
It was suddenly available.
The shocking ghoulag chronicle one day in the life of Ivan Denisovich was
published with Khrushchev's personal blessing in the cities.
A wave of new apartment blocks gave people something resembling that own
personal space for the first time in years for on travel,
it was suddenly opens within the party.
Dozens.
We're held accountable for their role in the purges,
although Khrushchev conveniently forgot to ask about his own involvement,
and 90 61 at Khrushchev even had stolen his body removed from Lennon's mausoleum
on Red Square.
That's same styling grants.
It was renamed vulgar grads.
It wasn't all sunshine and rainbows.
Of course,
there was still a secret police.
They were still do lags.
There was still a repression as well as the USSR rafter role.
The difference was that repression and decrease.
Jeff was harassment and intimidation and paying endless bribes.
Whereas in time so many men that the secret police were shooting millions of
people,
not that all of Khrushchev's reforms went well.
Vote.
In 1956 Khrushchev authorize the opening of a millions of acres of virgin land
in Siberia and Kazakhstan's a farming in an attempt to and the sort of famines
that had witnessed in Ukraine.
This went about as well as you would expect when you send an untrained people to
go and farm in Siberia.
It's pretty cold voice of the world though.
Khrushchev,
he was a breath of fresh air.
He talked about living in peaceful coexistence with the West and assigned from
the time he sell American reporters,
we will bury you.
He actually seemed to mean it in 1959 the USSR and the United States even hosted
joint expos in their countries showing off Soviet living to the Americans and
vice versa.
On July the 24th Khrushchev went,
so it's all the American Expo in Moscow where he bumps into none other than
Richard Nixon.
He stood before a model of an American kitchen and the two engaged in something
known as the kitchen debate.
It was a semi light hearted Wang measuring contest between the two nations in
the debates or Khrushchev and Nixon both argue why their system of government
was better.
Okay,
but I can play
and the way you will dominate the conversation,
you would have made a good lawyer,
Mark Khrushchev's,
notorious 10 bird could have turned it into a diplomatic incidents.
It instead became a symbol for how the u s and the Soviet Union might be able to
agree to disagree.
That same year with relations seemingly warming,
Khrushchev left the USSR and embarked on a tour of the USA for those who grew up
associating Chris Chefs name with the words missile crisis.
The image of the Russian Baron,
Iowa munching on hotdogs and chatting,
thanks and not true,
can seem almost comically strange yet.
History is sometimes pretty strange.
Khrushchev's tour of America,
the first by Soviet leader,
it was a media sensation or they're anti nuclear talks with Eisenhower went
nowhere.
The trip was mostly deems a PR success as 1960 dawn did even began to seem as if
the two supervisors,
they went destined to a not have they wanted all that.
It seems that the might be ringing the world's for communism and capitalism to
coexist.
Eh,
if anyone really did that though,
while they were about to get a fairly rude awakening
on our type of the fourth 1957 the u s I saw Sputnik one blast blasted off from
the plains of Kazakhstan becoming the first manmade satellite in orbit,
not four years later on April the 12th 1961 a Soviet rocket carries another
first into Orbitz.
This done.
It was a man named Yuri Gagarin.
On that day,
he became the first ever human to experience space flight for Soviet citizens.
These two phenomenal achievements were just yet more good news from the Chris
Jeff Thor over in the Pentagon though the American position,
it was one a watery.
It wasn't just because of the Soviets who making NASA leg like Hicks,
but also because those rockets were capable of delivering something much more
serious than cosmonauts and that was a course nuclear weapons.
These fears crystallized on to type of the 14th 1962 and I'm saying American spy
plane passing over the Cuba snapped a rather strange picture.
The previous couple of years had been Raul,
the strains between the United States and it's either neighbor.
In 1959 Fidel Castro comes to power on the back of a communist revolution,
not two years later,
the new JFK administration to try to invade the island and toppled Castro
resulting in an enormous grub that you've probably heard of called the Bay of
Pigs.
On top of that,
and relations had gone rather south with the USSR.
Khrushchev had reacted angrily to the Bay of Pigs and there was this image of
him banging his shoe on the table at the UN in 1960 that convinced the Americans
that he was a bit unstable as the spy plane pilot snapped his pictures and flew
away from that warm Caribbean Day.
He had no way of knowing that his images would soon lead the planet to the brink
of nuclear war.
The pictures showed a Soviet nuclear launch pad being construction in Cuba.
Apocalyptic missiles when now station just 19 miles from the u s mainland's.
When the news reached Washington,
the worlds it entered crisis mode,
Khrushchev's whole rationale was that the u s it installed it's own missiles in
Tuckey,
even closer to the USSR and the Cuban missiles went to America.
Surely the Americans would just have to learn to deal with it,
but the thought of an atomic bomb exploding over Miami or Houston at forced
Americans to hit back on the 22nd of October,
Jfk gave a televised address informing the wells about the missiles.
He punched a set off a naval blockade to stop more missiles reaching Cuba and
gave the u s s saw an ultimatum,
remove the missiles in Cuba or it's war in the Kremlin and Khrushchev,
he tried to hold us enough.
The USSR was already failing at the nuclear arms race.
If it lost its new outpost in Cuba,
who knew what would happen.
And thus began the highest stakes game of chicken and history.
On October the 24th Soviet ships carrying additional missiles reached the u s
naval blockade,
the two sides where one mistake from new PIA war,
three days later a US pilots was shot down over Cuba with tensions.
Now breaking points,
people across the planet again to prepare for the ends as any moments of the
human race could be snuffed out in a flash of atomic light.
The fact that it wasn't is simply do you to two pieces of paper on October the
28th 1960 to Khrushchev cracks.
He sent JFK to agenda notes.
The first said the Cuban nuclear facilities would be dismantled if the u s swore
to never launched another invasion of Cuba.
There's acan demanded that the u s nuclear missiles also be removed from tocky
hold.
Like the Kennedy Administration only publicly agreed to the first note.
They secretly let Moscow know that that abide by the second as well.
I'm just like that the weld snapped back from the abyss.
So what was going through Christian,
his mind as he sent those notes,
the American version has it that the crisis was simply a high stakes poker game
and the USSR linked fussed,
but maybe there was something more hand for all of his faults.
Khrushchev wasn't a psychopath.
He didn't want to destroy the world.
It was certainly his fault that the missile is in Cuba in the first place,
but maybe he also deserves credit for not seeing his dangerous bluff through.
Regardless,
the crisis ended without the planet burning.
The Soviets retreated and the Americans,
they kept their promises.
The next year a hotline was installed between the White House and the creme.
Lindsey prevent future apocalypses and his ladies and memoirs Khrushchev would
like to call the resolution to the crisis,
a personal triumph bus that were very few in Moscow who saw that way from the
moment that a u s biplane first took that photo ever.
Cuba,
his days in the Kremlin,
they were numbered.
The ripple effects of the Cuban missile crisis were felt across the globe in
Asia.
They became the final nail in the coffin for the relationship between the USSR
and China.
The Sino Soviet splits.
It began way back with Khrushchev's secret speech.
This,
it was the bungled missile crisis that convinced mau to break with Moscow
fingers.
Actually even go Chris,
Jeff,
the Foun in the structures of the communist party,
the perceived humiliation of Christian has climbed down,
made people question the leader in ways that they hadn't since Malin govs failed
coup.
Brad's all these reforms that gums Chris Jeff's had perhaps what the u s is on
needed was less liberalism and its more orthodoxy.
I mean they didn't want to go all the way back to stolen ism,
but you know maybe something just slightly less open and less tolerance.
And so Leonid Brezhnev,
a protege of Khrushchev and the fellow Ukrainian,
although in Reggie natives case had actually been born.
That native was also a deeply ambitious man.
Although Khrushchev was clearly grooming him to be a success,
a relative,
you didn't want to wait.
And now with the tide of opinion.
Finally turning against Khrushchev,
the pupil,
you can tunnel that small stock.
On October the 14th 1964 Khrushchev was on vacation in Georgia when Reggie never
launched as queue.
While every previous Soviet handover of power had been accompanied by bloodshed
this time things were almost orderly.
Restaurant of took control of the party audit Christian back to Moscow wins,
made them resign as a leader.
Why isn't he Khrushchev?
He accepted this early retirement and that was it for cruise chef,
the man who destocked and NYSED an MPI.
He was allowed to live,
but it was shunted off into anonymity.
Khrushchev,
he was forbidden from speaking aos.
The press were encouraged not to report on him and his name was quietly scrubbed
from Soviet life,
although bridge and didn't kill his old mentor,
how we felt about him,
his evidence from what happens when Khrushchev finally died on September the
11th 1971 while on his policy made headlines in the west,
the Soviet press,
they didn't mention it for 48 hours before finally putting out a small notice,
there was no state funeral.
There was no burial in the Kremlin wool less than a decade off to his left
office.
It seemed Khrushchev had already been forgotten,
but Khrushchev,
he wasn't done yet.
Over a decade after his death,
the group of younger communists,
they came to power known as the children of the 20th Party Congress.
They were the generation of party members who watched enraptured is Khrushchev
made his secret speech.
One of them,
well,
that was Mikhail Gorbachev and the late 1980s Gorbachev would implement his own
version of Khrushchev's reforms known as glasnost and Perestroika that
eventually lead to the USSR as disillusion,
nor was Gorbachev the only communist leader that Khrushchev influenced the
crease.
You have.
Thor had been credited with inspiring everything from the Prague spring in 1968
to dang shall opening of the Chinese markets in the 1980s almost every
liberalizing strain of communism.
It can be traced back to the secret speech.
So at the ends of all of that,
once the historical verdict on the crease,
Jeff,
as we said at the start,
for many in the west,
it's the missile crisis so that suddenly that was a huge part of its premise
ship.
There was more than that.
Khrushchev was the first Soviet premiere to stop the mass killings to end the
daily terror of life.
Understanding.
Sure,
the society he led was still woefully repressive,
but it was an improvements by orders of magnitude from the one that had come
before him in another timeline without Khrushchev fields have one of the
Stalinist seizing controlled in 1953 ends,
you'll have many more decades of unbridled mass Smeta.
You'd never have the thought,
you'd never have the stylization Jeff.
He may have had his faults,
but in many ways he was also the right man at the right time.
History may judge them harshly for his mistakes,
but it shouldn't forget his successes.
So I already have you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below.
Also,
don't forget to subscribe and hit that notification bell.
We put out new videos several times a week.
So doing that while notifying you about those also,
why not check out my other channel called top tens you'll find a link to that
below,
and as always,
thank you for watching.